الينا من جنين مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار ليث
اطلعنا على اخر تطورات الوضع في جنين وهل
انسحبت قوات
الاحتلال نعم انسحبت قوات الاحتلال بعد
عمليه عسكريه استمرت لقرابته السبع ساعات
في مدينه جنين وفي مخيم جنين حيث دفع
الاحتلال بما يزيد عن 20 اليه عسكريه
برفقه اربعه جرافات وصلت الى المدينه بعد
ذلك تم قسم هذه الاليات الى قسمين قسم
توجه الى مخيم جنين حيث بدا الاحتلال
باعمال التجريف والتخريب في انحاء متفرقه
من محيط المخيم تق تحديدا دوار العوده الى
الغرب من المدينه وايضا شمال المدينه
وتحديدا منطقه ال يعني الدوار الرئيسي
وايضا دوار الحص صان المتاخم للمخيم القوى
الاخرى تقدمت نحو انحاء متفرقه من المدينه
حيث وصلت الى حي الجابريات حيث نتواجد في
هذه اللحظات قامت باعمال التدمير كما
تشاهدون في هذه الصوره في انحاء متفرقه
ايضا من المدينه حيث وصلت الى شارع البريد
دوار شارع حيفا وايضا شارع الناصره دوار
الداخليه وايضا المنطقه الشرقيه والمنطقه
الصناعيه وا سوق المدينه حيث قامت باعمال
التدمير الواسعه التي شملت المدينه على حد
سواء لم تقتصر فقط على المخيم وسط
اشتباكات مسلحه وانفجارات لعدد من العبوات
الناسفه الاشتباكات كانت في في الحقيقه
متقطعه طوال الليل و بنفس الوقت متواصله
بين الفينه والاخرى هناك تواجد كان لاليات
الاحتلال ايضا في كافه المحاور في مدينه
جنين او محيط مدينه جنين بالتزامن مع هذا
الاقتحام حيث شهدت المدينه طوال الليل
حاله من الاغلاق الواسع والحصار لكافه
المحاور في
المدينه بفعل اليات الاحتلال وجرافات التي
جاءت في هذه الليله ل وحسب الهدف وكما
تحدث الاحتلال بهدف ازاله العبوات الناسفه
التي وضعتها المقاومه المقاومه والتي كان
اخرها وتفجير اليه عسكريه ادى لمقتل مجنده
على الاقل بحسب بيان جيش الاحتلال
بالتزامن مع هذا الاقتحام كان هناك
اقتحامات متواصله لمدن الضفه الغربيه
المحتله حيث شهدت مناطق عده طول كرم رام
الله جنين وابيت لحم والخليل اقتحامات
متواصله حتى ساعات الصباح في ساعات الصباح
اقتحمت مدينه نابلس حاصر البلده القديمه
في في المدينه ولا تزال اليات الاحتلال
وقوات الاحتلال تطبق الخناق والحصار على
كافه
ارجاء البلده القديمه في نابلس وسط
اشتباكات ومواجهات عنيفه في انحاء متفرقه
من المدينه لم تقتصر فقط على البلده
القديمه وانما هناك مواجهات في كافه
المحاور حتى المحيطه في المدينه وفي
البلده القديمه هنا في جنين انسحب
الاحتلال صباح هذا اليوم بعد قام بتدمير
البنى التحتيه وعدد من الطرقات والمحال
التجاريه وايضا السوق المدينه الذي شهد
تجريف في ساعات الليل
وتدمير لبعض البسطات والمحال التجاريه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر ليث جعار مراسلنا من
جنين